Сьогодні він - відповідальний за збір пакунків з допомогою у цьому волонтерському хабі.
І знає про кожну річ, яка є тут.
Ми допомагаємо з одягом і продуктовими наборами.
Також у нас в наявності підгузки.
Тут у нас все посортовано по місцям - S, L - за розмірами.
Щосуботи у вільний від уроків час 13-річний Даня Мезенцев приходить у штаб благодійної організації "Bucha Help".
Тут він сортує та збирає гуманітарну допомогу, а потім звідси надсилає її поштою,
вантажить у автівки волонтерів або особисто доставляє у Гостомель, Бучу та Ірпінь
переселенцям, які втратили домівки.
Це на першу адресу, ці два пакунки на другу адресу.
Там написано. І це на третю і четверту адреси.
Оце все виносити?
Так-так! Ми все це повеземо.
Ага! Добре!
У Дані є дорослі наставники-волонтери, до яких в штаб батьки особисто привозять сина.
Тут його навчили вести облік допомоги, складати її та відправляти в інші міста.
Щось в Дніпро, щось в Запорізьку область.
От це збираєш і ми сьогодні відправляємо!
Я хвилювалася, бо це дитина! Але ж нічого! Він впорався!
Все, що він робить, ніхто його не "запрягає", хоче - робить, не хоче - ні.
Я знаю, коли треба допомога, два "зелених свистки", і Даня вже тут!
Перша зустріч Дані з волонтерами відбулася зовсім не тут, де він зараз - на Київщині.
А за обставин, коли він, його менші братик і сестричка та батьки самі потребували допомоги,
живучи у підвалі свого будинку в Бахмуті.
Пробило у нас п’ятий поверх - повна хата голубів. Мародери у нас винесли все!
Родина Мезенцевих до останнього не наважувалася поїхати з рідного міста,
навіть коли почалася холодна зима без електроенергії та опалення.
То ми їдемо, то ми не їдемо, просто не було куди!
Був колодязь, ми ходили з колодязя брали воду.
Пічка, у нас була своя кімнатка, ми туди спустили диван.
Я і троє дітей на дивані, чоловік поруч з пічкою спав, бо дрова треба було вночі підкидати.
За таких умов Даня навчався у 6 класі онлайн.
І лише завдяки місцевому пункту незламності, в якому був доступ до інтернету.
Туди хлопець ходив щоденно навчатися і там вперше побачив роботу волонтерів.
Заходиш туди, а там телевізор працює, новини.
І так тепло стає! Там тепло, чайок, хоча на вулиці холодно.
Коли перший раз прийшов, пам’ятаю, подарунки дарували.
Я завжди захоплювався волонтерами!
Вони такі були теплі душею!
І тоді я теж захотів стати волонтером - хоч якось допомагати!
Та коли російська ракета влучила в дім, де жила родина,
вони наважилися остаточно залишити підвал
та евакуюватися з допомогою поліцейського екіпажу "Білі янголи".
Потім - дорога потягом до Дніпра, звідки Мезенцеви вирушили до Києва.
Там вони вийшли на зв'язок з волонтерами "Bucha Help".
Ми взяли родину! Наступного дня ми приїхали з пакунками,
бо в квартирі, де вони зараз мешкають - також це волонтерська допомога
для родини з трьох дітей, мами, тата і песика - там нічого не було.
Ми все почали спочатку. І так познайомилися!
Зараз вони мають змогу жити, працювати, діти вчаться!
Вже тут, у Бучі, на свій День народження - 18 лютого - Даня загадав бажання:
завітати в гості до волонтерів, які допомогли його родині,
побачити, як вони збирають гуманітарку для інших переселенців
і нарешті здійснити задумане -  долучитися до роботи благодійників.
Це був подарунок! Всім потрібна допомога!
Для мне також це було незвичайно, це було дійсно його волонтерське перше завдання:
приїхала машина з Литви, привезла гуманітарну допомогу.
І ось Даня якраз вивантажував цю гуманітарну допомогу на хабі!
Він приходить, він спілкується, він розмовляє, він щось хоче, він цікавиться,
він допомагає і витрачає свій особистий час на те, щоб це зробити!
Багато людей так не роблять.
Вони не можуть дати самі собі раду після того всього, вони отямитися не можуть.
А є люди, котрі розуміють, що треба допомагати,
бо допомога як ланцюгова реакція - вона допомагає-допомагає…
Я пишаюся цією дитиною! Ну що, поїхали!
За три місяці Даня вже спробував себе у різних ролях як волонтер,
та найулюбленіша його частина волонтерства - розвозити пакунки з гумдопомогою особисто тим,
хто на них чекає. Цього разу це кілька родин в Ірпені.
Тримайте! Можу вам допомогти донести!
Молодець, звісно! Молодчинка! Не можу! З Бахмута! Рік уже дома не були. В мене діти з Дружківки, з Краматорська…
Ірина не може стримати сліз, бо землячка Дані.
Вона так само втратила рідний дім у Бахмуті.
Каже, на власні заощадження винаймає з дітьми житло в Ірпені,
втім на новому місці важко впоратися без допомоги волонтерів. А її щомісяця стає все менше.
Будем триматися! В нас хороший мер, обіцяв, що все відбудують!
Не може стримати сліз, приймаючи пакунок допомоги від Дані й інша переселенка - Лідія.
Вона втратила дім у сусідньому місті - в Гостомелі.
І вимушено мешкає у небайдужих людей в Ірпені.
Ви зараз тут живете?
Так, проживаю, борсаюся в городі! Отак стараюся, не сиджу, коротше, не сиджу!
З кожним і кожною, кому Даня везе пакунки з допомогою від благодійників -
він охоче знайомиться, підтримує і розповідає, що привіз.
Тут вам туалетний папір! Ось кросівки! Тут консерви…
Дитино!
Допомога - це не просто ти кинув коробку в машину, привіз і дав!
Ні, це якось з душею треба!
Ось так дав, щоб побачити ці усмішки!
Радість, спілкування, нові друзі, це неможливо передати!
Вони це розуміють, як ніхто!
Вони розуміють, як ніхто - діти! Дуже тяжко!
Даня сам зізнається: він щиро співчуває і розуміє усіх, кому допомагає.
Я розумію цих людей, я це пройшов…
Життя в підвалі, вода з колодязя. Як день бабака.
Люди не відчувають себе самотніми! Ми їм допомагаємо!
Мрія Дані - в майбутньому опанувати професію,
завдяки якій він зможе бути корисним українцям.
У списку хлопця - поліцейський, лікар-педіатр та журналіст.
А поки, каже: його місія продовжити навчання попри все,
і допомогти якомога більшій кількості таких, як він.
І одного дня, вірить Даня, він таки зможе повернутися додому - в рідний Бахмут.